um you know I'm going to rewired it
because uh if if someone like Netflix or
something approached you guys to make an
animated version of this would that be
something you would like to see not that
I'm not asking is it would you like to
see this in an animated version Oh I
think that's like the dopest idea ever
like heard that but comedy I think so
too that's all the questions that I
could ask
I am so because like kick this to be
again screams like Saturday morning
cartoon videos
anime style like I could see it like
I've already you know if my marketing
I'm into the toys
808 to be already on the Mount Rushmore
for mascots for Xbox
you know what we could do with them
yeah salute salute to that man it's been
tremendous to see the success you know
and again the way you guys have